this freedom of self-consciousness when
it appeared as a conscious manifestation
in the history of spirit it has as we
know been called stoicism its principle
is that consciousness is a being that
thinks and that consciousness holds
something to be essentially important or
true and good only insofar as it thinks
it to be such
in this very short paragraph 198 Hegel
is going to identify he's going to give
a name for this new shape of
consciousness that has emerged in 197
but was already there starting to emerge
in the end of the master-slave dialectic
in paragraph 196 he is going to say it's
called stoicism and this is very
interesting for a variety of reasons is
that we're going to see in this this
paragraph and other paragraphs yet to
come
what is that you know this is a time in
the phenomenology where we can say AHA
here's what Hegel is actually referring
to determinately stoicism is a
philosophical school one of the very
important philosophical schools of
ancient culture ancient Greek and Roman
culture and it emerges in what's called
the Hellenistic age that is they you
know this this time in which the Greek
city-states are to a certain degree
losing their identity of their freedom
their importance as communities and
becoming part of part of larger social
matrices you know what we're going to
see happening around this time is the
the conquest by the Macedonians of
Greece and that of a whole bunch of
other areas including Persia the ancient
enemy of Greece Egypt
you know uniting things into one you
know the economy was the word that was
used we're gonna make economic a this
this vast household which then would
break up into successor States which
would war against each other try to try
to carry out the same sort of dynamics
of power but no longer on the basis of
what we might call you know city-state
ethnic identities in which an individual
would be part of
you rooted in that community same thing
is happening by the way on the other
side of the Mediterranean as you know
two great arch rivals Rome and Carthage
are themselves you know empires that are
fighting against each other and against
the Greeks and against you know soon to
come you know the semi Greek states in
an appearance there's all sorts of
fascinating history happening here
what's really important as far as the
movement that is stoicism a
philosophical movement what's important
here from an Italian perspective it is
that a new shape of consciousness has
emerged as self conscious as on the
scene in the form of a you know a
philosophy in the form of some sort of
body of doctrine not quite the same
thing as a religion we're going to see
that religion plays an incredibly
important role in the later paragraphs
of this section of self-consciousness
but in terms of a way of life not only a
way of thinking and we're going to see
there's a lot a lot of talk here about
thought but a lot as part of an entire
attitude of life so Hegel says stoicism
is the conscious manifestation of the
freedom of self-consciousness in history
it's not the only one but it is a early
manifestation of that and it's one that
is going to recur over and over again
there are going to be revivals of
stoicism as time goes on we're going to
see stoicism historically not not in
terms of Hegel's projects so much but
historically become very important
within the Roman Empire and all of its
it's sort of tributaries culturally
economically then it's going to end up
become
more or less absorbed into Christianity
if you look at the practices of the
ascetic monks out in the desert and you
know something about stoicism because
you've you know studied your epictetus
or you studied your Seneca you're going
to see quite a bit of commonalities
between them on some very important
points about how you should conduct
yourself how you should use your mind
how you should cultivate your will and
we're going to see stoicism arise out of
its ashes again in the Renaissance where
people self-identify the Stoics we're
going to see today that there are modern
Stoics there's quite a few of them so I
don't need a single about my name but
who view this this attitude this this
form of life this form of consciousness
this shape this Gestalt as something not
only particularly useful for them to get
through the day
but as revelatory of truth revelatory of
reality so Hegel is really a courting
stoicism what might seem to be a very
high compliment in saying all right this
is what happens next on the other hand
it's not quite so much of a compliment
as we're gonna see in the next three
paragraphs because stoicism for Hegel at
least it's an important development but
it turns out to be kind of a dead end
it doesn't live up to its promises and
this can be dialectically revealed and
then the stoic will quit being a stoic
in any case there's there's a importance
here of historical development stoicism
only shows up on the scene and stoicism
not as you know certain elements of
stoicism like being a tough guy warrior
or things like that but is it a
full-blood philosophy when in the world
when human history is ready for it
so there has to be this
through the master-slave dialectic
before stoicism can they actually become
a going concern now he's going to tell
us a little bit about what central the
stoicism here in these passages that I
put up on the board and parsed out a
little bit for you he says that stoicism
has the the following point of view
let's call it there's two main points
one leads directly into the other
consciousness is a being that thinks
yeah you know when I say that if you've
ever read your dick heard that you know
immediately is going to remind you of
the heart meditation to what am I about
being that thinks what is it to think
that's where it gets very interesting
because to think doesn't just mean to be
totally isolated from things but it
doesn't mean that there is the
connection to the subject so there's
this [ __ ] to subjectivity thinking can
take on many different modes we're gonna
see that's the case they curve by the
way is in some respects of neo stoic so
now he goes on and he says what does
this really mean this means that
something has essential importance or in
the German phase and I we're gonna see
this word Bazin show up again down below
here so it's a little bit important to
pay attention to to these these
interconnections
something he has essential importance or
you can say essentiality or you can say
is an essence there's there's different
ways of framings but you understand what
we're talking but something has a
sensuality to it something has a kind of
legitimacy legitimate demand upon our
attention as being important when when
or only it is so far as consciousness
thinks it to be such as how Miller
translates it now the German is a little
bit different than that here the
emphasis tends to be
what is happening to the thing that has
essential importance to being thought
right
he and Hegel actually says only insofar
and then here's the Germans are in
décadas big ism for health this has to
do more with the being that's doing the
thinking the self-consciousness or in
order to feel like consciousness right
consciousness in its relationship in its
comportment to the thing treats itself
or acts as a thinking essence a thinking
being and so there's a there's a you
know two things going on here
consciousness is thinking the thing and
we've seen this already with with you
know sense certainty and perception and
enforcing the understanding that to to
perceive to you know into its to to mark
out to understand something it implies a
relationship with a thing that always
seems to be receding from our graphs
that's what we call the vanishing moment
there's something eluding us in the
thing stoicism is going to you might say
hug the thing tight in thought it's
going to say this is what it is that has
essentially only insofar as it is an
object of thought for me the thinking
thing that's essential now notice what
else he says here something has
essential importance or is true or is
good truth and goodness epistemological
and moral qualities or it might say
bases because that's really what
epistemology and morale or moral theory
moral moral philosophy
is oriented by how do we get to the
truth how do we assure ourselves that
what we think is true is true how do we
know that what we think is actually good
is good this is talking about what the
Stoics are going to call the criterion
that we're going to see Hegel talk about
a little bit more in future paragraphs
so keep all of this in mind as we now
plow through and Hegel's treatment of
stoicism
the manifold self differentiating
expanse of life with all its detail and
complexity is the object on which desire
and work operate this manifold activity
is now contracted into the simple
positing of differences in the pure
movement of thinking essential
importance no longer attaches to the
difference as a specific thing or as
consciousness of the specific natural
existence as a feeling or as a desire
and its object whether this is positive
by myself or by an alien consciousness
what alone has importance is the
difference posited by thought or the
difference which from the very first is
not distinct from myself
this consciousness accordingly has a
negative attitude towards the Lord and
bondsmen relationship as Lord it does
not have its truth in the bondsman nor
as bondsman is its truth in the Lord's
will and in his service on the contrary
whether on the throne or in Chains in
the utter dependence of its individual
existence its aim is to be free and to
maintain that lifeless indifference
which steadfastly withdraws from the
bustle of existence alike from being
active is passive into the simple
essentiality of thought self will is the
freedom which entrenches itself in some
particularity and is still invited while
stoicism is the freedom which always
comes directly out of bondage and
returns into the peer University of
thought as a universal form of the world
spirit stoicism could only appear on the
scene in a time of universal fear and
bondage but also a time of universal
culture which it had raised itself to
the level of thought
in paragraph 199 we're getting a much
longer and in many respects richer
discussion about what is actually taking
place through stoicism through the
comportment through the way of relating
oneself to the world into oneself that
is happening through stoic philosophy
not just through stoic philosophy as you
know something stay contained in a book
but the stoic philosophy has lived as a
comportment towards the world and as
we're going to see there is a kind of
disengagement that's happening that
Hegel is noting from the start and
Stoics would agree they would say yes
indeed there are many things from which
we think that you know we're too
entangled and must withdraw ourselves in
order that we can cure ourselves or or
at least you know carry on the therapy
somewhat it will cease this partly as an
advance and partly as where stoicism is
going to found her so let's look at how
this this comes about he you notice that
I've got up on the board two sorts of
ways that the stoic can be oriented one
of the has to do with the orientation
towards life and we've talked quite a
bit about life both in earlier sections
also in self-consciousness quite a bit
life doesn't just mean one thing but
here in this context the the way too
much Hegel is using life it is to refer
to the sort of manifold diversity of
things going on that committee the
experience that can be engaged with we
might think of it as you know the the
beings that are and their various ways
of doing the things that they're
involved with that we can't quite wrap
our head around and we can't have one
single orientation towards unless we
withdraw from it unless we treat life as
a
of universal life by its own nature
while being in a universe where as we
saw earlier in self-consciousness a kind
of genus a captain it also by the fact
that it differentiates itself into it
splits itself into you know what he's
calling great detail great complexity
there is no one single thing that
exemplifies life it is in its profusion
you might say so he talks about the
manifold self differentiating expanse of
life right later he's going to call this
the bustle of existence beautiful phrase
used by the translator there in all of
its detail and complexity is an object
for the given person an object for the
human person in what way well at this
point it's not the naturalist out there
you know classifying all the different
bugs in the Amazon or anything like that
it's the much more easy to relate to
world that provokes our desire and that
compels our work and we relate to the
world outside of ourselves the world of
life the world of living things that are
not just this living thing through
desire and through work through many
types of desire through many kinds of
work and the two of these are intimately
connected as we saw so he says this is
the object on which desire and work
operate and if we're not thinking about
what we're doing we ended up having a
kind of you know what phenomenologist
has called the natural attitude where we
just take things for granted I've gotta
get to the bus stop
why because I've got to catch the bus to
get to my job why because I need to make
some money why because then I can come
you know home but hit the store on the
way and get myself the pizza that I'm
going to throw in the oven so that I can
eat tonight and maybe watch some TV why
well because I've got to get up and work
the next day so I don't want to do
anything too stressful and
there's this whole set of wives but
ultimately end up being kind of a cycle
and unsatisfying as soon as we start
asking the why or you know which
sometimes and you know amazing us as
well right those are all possibilities
in life and life is related to by the
stoic by every other human being through
desire and work but that's not the only
way that it can happen so he goes on he
says this manifold activity is now
contracted into the simple positing of
differences in the pure moment of
thinking so there's this I've got this
arc here of differences you know when
life is differentiating itself as it
constantly is as it constantly has been
always like a pre history of it that
evades our our grasp in the present this
complexity this richness gets reduced to
a different on the weight of
understanding difference which is
abstract because it is difference on the
part of thought he says essential
importance no longer attaches to the
difference as a specific thing the
essential importance doesn't lie on this
side as a specific thing and as a
particular right or as consciousness of
a specific natural existence or as a
feeling a feeling that the person over
here he has towards these things or as
desire and it's object where it's going
back in German right whether this is
positive by myself or by an alien
consciousness well that's where this is
going to come in over here the
master-slave dialectic but it doesn't
necessarily have to be master of slave
we can also think in terms of how you
know we get to know what we should
desire what we should work on so it was
through somebody domineering and you
know making us afraid and then
we have to pull they changed our lives
oftentimes it sits through seeing how
everybody else in the world does things
think about the way that recommendations
work you know we're all familiar with
because a lot of line stuff with amma
design recommendations with the owl now
they actually am starting to produce and
they hammered out their social networks
that are supposed to rate people and not
just rate people like the ng listing
over how they do their job but rate
people in general what is going on with
that is there is there a master telling
you how to behave no you actually
willingly take that information in and
you're like i could use this but what's
happening there is some other alien
consciousness is telling you about this
world out there that that great world
and about parts of myths
now the stoic withdraws from all of that
they withdraw from all of that by saying
i am going to emphasize this aspect of
thought that is what i really am
that is what is most mean all this other
stuff isn't really me
it is me only to the extent that i have
myself allowed them those parts to sort
of captivate me to intrude into to use a
famous metaphor of the Stoics the inner
Citadel
so the stoic locates their own reality
on this side the side of thought the
side of consciousness it says what will
only has importance is the difference
posited by thought or a difference which
from the very first is not distinct from
myself because I am the one thinking all
of this stuff out here the parts that I
allow to get in I am the one who is in
control of it I you know this is what
was so liberating about stoicism and
remains liberating today is this sense
that I don't have to just take my cues
from ones out here or from awesome other
self
just as telling me how it is I can to
think this out for myself
now of course if I think it out in ways
that aren't going to work and I stick to
those ways I'm going to be profoundly
unhappy but I have the possibility of
being creative being happy by resisting
you know all these sort of lures that
are being put out there so he says this
consciousness accordingly has a negative
attitude towards the Lord and bondsmen
relationship towards the master/slave
relationship what does it do in fact it
nullifies it it leaves it in place
empirically it doesn't deny that there
are power relations
it doesn't deny it for example as
epictetus will tell us you know somebody
can come a lie and say I'm going to put
you in irons if you don't do it I say
says well you can feather my leg but you
can't actually fetter my moral purpose
or will however you want to translate
probably raises the whole conversation
be about that that's quite interesting
so nobody can really be a master and
nobody can really be a slave except in a
sort of arbitrary and curable sense from
the perspective of stoicism he says as
Lord it doesn't have its truth in the
bondsman if you're lucky enough to be
been born award like Marcus Aurelius the
stomach Emperor all right well you you
act like a good lord then you act like a
good master you run the Empire and don't
take advantage of everybody and try to
make justice happen and you know when
you run into all the jerks out there
that you've prepared yourself for every
single morning by saying today I'm gonna
run into people like this this this this
you've sealed yourself against the world
you don't need anyone to be your slave
you're not getting your fulfillment
through dominating somebody else and
deriving something from their work from
you know they're restrained designer
likewise he says nor does a bondsman as
its truth in the Lord's will and in his
sir
you know you may be a slave Epictetus
himself as a slave and you do have to
serve you know if you don't want to get
whipped or beaten or sold the lot for
all these other terrible things that
could happen to you but the master
doesn't control you
the master controls your body or much
food you eat or things like that but
they don't control you what's really the
essence of human being in you
he says the bondsmen doesn't have its
truth and the Lord's will in service on
the country whether on the throne or in
Chains there's a beautiful formula here
in the utter dependence of its
individual existence its aim is to be
free when we see Emma's dialectic
happening between the individual
existence the individual existing human
being and the universal freedom it is in
a certain respect something that has to
always be made intensely particular and
yet it always evades any particular or
specific formulation for example of it
you can't you know bottle of freedom up
and in that that spot right freedom is
also a universal it's a universal that's
so Universal that it cannot be an
abstract Universal that's something
that's lying behind Hegel's philosophy
as a whole so you know somebody says
it's Amos to be free and to maintain
that lifeless indifference which
steadfastly withdraws from the bustle of
existence
I won't even cross this out because what
the stomach does is not just nullify
everything and say you don't exist
screw you because that would just be
merely reactive the stomach withdraws
they don't have anything to do with the
bustle of existence they are in the
middle of and of course epic teams for
example twice about you know I woke up
this morning and somebody came in they
broke into my place and they took some
of my stuff that's you know being caught
in the muscle of existence
he says but he had more native it the
night it obviously or at least he
thought he did so I'm not going to let
it bother me you know he took something
native brass honey
I'll go get something made of clay and
now he won't steal it it'll work just as
well that's a very stoic attitude
towards things so he goes ahead and he
says alight from being active is passive
into the simple essentiality of thought
that's what he's withdrawing to the
stoic is pulling themself away from the
world this is indifference now you're
not going to see this in Hegel's text
here these are two and agreed terms that
I get used quite often by by the Stoics
also of their Latin forms you know
Libertas and Athiya right boobie does
and the indifference that he's talking
about there really consists in in his
two sides
ah the theta is not being disturbed by
things literally not suffering right
come from it's worth half a they feeling
a succoring literally something that
somebody else or the world imposes upon
you this indifference allows the stoic
not to have to feel bad things when they
happen but it also requires the stoic
not to get too caught up in the good
things when they happen to this is a bit
more that's a sort of primitive concept
this is a more positive concept and
level-10 area means freedom it means the
state of being a free person and this
can apply eat into the slave who's a
stoic the slave can be free insofar as
they are a thinking beating and insofar
as this other stuff out here doesn't
really matter to them and it's up to
them it's their choice whether this
stuff matters to them or not
so he says self will is the freedom
which entrenches itself in some
particularity and is still in bondage
that's a different kind of
than other with theory the the self-will
locates itself out here somewhere right
in some object in some place someplace
outside of the self which is vulnerable
to this entire you know mishmash of
things that is life
which can be trapped in the master-slave
dialectic as well self will is that
freedom that's not the can freedom that
you want
he says stoicism is the freedom which
comes out of bondage and returns into
the pure universality of thought but
whose worth you know we have to unpack a
little bit so if I'm stoic and you're a
stoic my thoughts and your thoughts
really have a lot in common because
insofar as were rational I don't want to
say we're the same person but we have
the same rational structure to our minds
insofar as you become more rational
insofar as I become more rational we
become more like each other we're more
able to live in the kind of Cosmopolitan
you know unity that the Stoics espoused
as a social idea so here's what he says
here's how he brings us to a close and
this is quite important going back to
the historical matter we've been talking
about historical development we haven't
done an awful lot of that so far here in
the text now haven't but now we are
going to do this more and more and more
we're going to say there's a determinate
stage of history of human development
that the dialectic needed to get to and
now we can go on to its next stuff after
you know exhaust that stage he says
stoicism could only appear on the scene
in a time of universal fear and bond of
slavery stoicism could only come on the
scene at a time when anybody could
naturally become a slave where you know
the sort of small Commonwealth's had
been replaced by these larger and more
in some sense abstract and in some sense
more arbitrary imperial structures where
politics you know a lot of people think
that stoicism is the result of the Greek
city-state disappearing and so Plato and
Aristotle views are just kind of
old-fashioned stoicism comes on the
scene for people who aren't political
but no that's not really the truth about
stoicism if you read great stomach
thinkers but it's a different sort of
environment that they're in one in which
anybody could wind up becoming an
emperor and anybody could end up
becoming a slave and as we see the
history develop that happens more and
more often right there's a lot of
ferment that's taking place also a time
of universal fear anybody could become
vulnerable to the things that are
happening this is a time in which a kind
of globalization is occurring and it's
not just bringing you know political
transformations or economic catastrophes
it's also bringing in barbarian tribes
swinging around and doing what they do
which usually isn't very good for
civilized people and diseases coming
through and great opportunities at the
same time arising there's you know the
ancient world there's a lot going on at
the time at stoicism what's happening he
says this is a time of the universal
culture build remember that term
building that we saw so important in the
preface bid alone is what he's referring
to here when he says it raised itself to
the level of thought the thought is
taking place through building through
images through the things that form a
culture and you know when we look back
at this by the last thing I'm gonna say
about this when we look back on
Hellenistic culture what we're often
tempted to think of
are things like vases and museums and
you know literary texts plays that we
could put on costumes that people have
that's all very important but what's
more important is the people who
produced it the people who transmitted
that culture who build that culture who
argued against each other who allowed
that culture to have a framework culture
is always human culture so stone ax sysm
plays an incredibly important role in
the development according to Hegel of
consciousness in the West
you